this is so funny
radical and repugnant reactionary
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor green
started complaining about how student
loan forgiveness which Joe Biden is now
doing
is uh it's bad it's unfair that some
people don't have to pay back loans they
took I mean they took out a loan and now
they don't have to pay it back and it
turns out that Marjorie Taylor green
took out a nearly two hundred thousand
dollar PPP loan that was the money uh
made available to businesses in the
pandemic relief packages during the
Trump and Biden uh pandemic relief
packages and it was forgiven she didn't
have to pay it back isn't that just the
best listen to this here's Marjorie
Taylor green attacking the Biden student
loan debt relief that that's why they're
the party where you don't have to pay
back loans that's why they're the party
that is just ripping our country apart
and Joe Biden is wrong he can't break
the law and just forgive everyone's
student loan debt it just doesn't work
that way right the Democrats are the
party where you don't have to pay back
loans and then we find out that the
Marjorie Taylor green and husband
business Taylor commercial received a
loan for a hundred and eighty two
thousand dollars
and they had a hundred and eighty three
thousand dollars forgiven why is the
amount forgiven more than the loan
amount well they also had a crude
interest for given isn't that nice that
loan was reportedly for employee wages
of course as with any of the there's so
much PPP fraud the IRS is investigating
generally we don't have any reason to
believe they're specifically
investigating the Marjorie Taylor green
loan but how much of that money in
theory for employee wages actually went
to Marjory Taylor Green's employees
that's a very very good question and by
the way when she says it's the Democrats
who are the party of not paying back
debts she supported Trump trump who
often didn't pay debts often didn't pay
people that he owed money to now I do
want to mention there is some
consistency here
I have to sort of concede
it's pretty obvious hypocrisy but
there's one way you can interpret this
in which Marjorie Taylor green is being
consistent she's about compassion for
businesses when it comes to finances but
not for individuals and in that sense
it's coherent with her philosophy to the
extent we can call it a philosophy that
she's mad about individuals not having
to pay back loans but she's fine with
businesses not having to pay them back
even when it's all a complete sham what
a lot of these businesses did with the
PPP money but there it is Marjorie
Taylor green a hypocrite a Wednesday
August 31st 6 PM Eastern we are doing a
members only Town Hall it will be
broadcast live to everyone but only our
existing members will be invited to
participate in this one and chat with me
we will be streaming it on YouTube
twitch and Facebook but if you want to
participate you do it via our Discord at
davidpackman.com Discord and of course
to be invited did you must be a member
at joinpakman.com I'll remind you about
it next week
one of our sponsors today is Bluetooth a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as Viagra and
Cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month's supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence when
it's time all you have to do is take a
short quiz on their website a licensed
doctor approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of Bluetooth tablets are made in the
USA the entire process is just a few
clicks go to bluetooth.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code Pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping